we're inside one of the homes in the
balata refugee camp in Nablus that was
raided over the course of a 15-hour
operation by Israeli soldiers this is
the fourth major operation to happen in
this community in a week this is one of
four homes that the Israelis apparently
want demolished they were looking for
someone they broke in through the door
over here and we'll just give you a
sense of how much Devastation happens
when one of these raids takes place in
this community they've basically
overturned every single cupboard and
shelf every Closet in this home every
room you look in every single room is
completely overturned and if you see
there damage to a photograph of the
cabba in Mecca so that doesn't seem
necessarily like it represented any sort
of security threat but apparently
Israeli forces are looking for weapons
uh they're looking for anything
suspicious they confiscate
identification cards cell phones and
basically turn entire homes completely
inside out they damaged Electronics
there's refrigerators here that are no
longer functioning the kitchen is
completely unusable every Appliance in
this home was damaged what electronic
appliances represent in terms of a
threat to the Israeli forces seems
unclear people living here say it is
meant to create a long-term financial
burden continue to perpetuate this sense
of fear and intimidation and frustration
that these communities feel this home
like several we've seen in the past few
weeks we've seen several just today all
with the same Mo 15 hours of this kind
of
ongoing intimidation through these raids
just in the Bata refugee camp again this
is the fourth time to happen in the
course of a week and what people here
are telling us is they are very worried
that is the ceasefire in Gaza moves
forward that as the guns go silent in
Gaza then pressure by the Israeli forces
on communities like this in the occupied
West Bank will only continue to go up
Zan basravi Al jazer in the balata
refugee camp in nablas